[Music]
on this monday night fresh optimism in
the development of a covid19 vaccine
the potential new shot in the arm we
need to stay strong and
hang in there a few more months why it
could be
significant and what's still unknown
kobit 19 cases are climbing across
canada that calls for tougher crackdowns
and lockdowns
and the confusing messaging in ontario
and bc
joe biden's pandemic plea it doesn't
matter who you voted for
we can save tens of thousands of lives
what the next commander-in-chief wants
all americans to start doing
now and a father's grief the tragic
twist in the canadian veteran's mission
to find his son's final resting place
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us i
am not in the studio at the moment
because i've just returned from covering
the presidential election in the u.s
and i'm quarantining for the next two
weeks so there is no crew with me and
the set looks a bit rudimentary but
we're going to carry on with the news
and we begin tonight with what could be
a first step out of all the restrictions
we are living under
a vaccine developed by the companies
pfizer and biontech
has shown early promise preliminary
results
show it is more than 90 percent
effective at protecting people from
covet 19.
experts do caution the human clinical
trials are still underway
and more data is needed but today's news
is fueling hopes a coronavirus vaccine
could be within reach
we see the light at the end of the
tunnel we are hopeful
we are getting there because our
scientists are working incredibly hard
the pfizer vaccine is one of 11
candidates in late stage phase 3 trials
it enrolled nearly 44 000 participants
in six countries
and raised no safety concerns half the
group received two doses of the vaccine
the other half got a placebo 94 of the
participants have developed covid19
it's believed most of them were in the
placebo group that does not mean
this vaccine is approved for use yet
more work needs to be done
but no vaccine has gone from the drawing
board to showing signs of promise
in such a short period of time abigail
beeman has our top story tonight
a great day for science it is a great
day for humanity
pfizer's ceo says he felt overwhelmed to
learn of the 90
effectiveness rate i believe this is
likely the most significant
medical advance in the last hundred
years we were thinking
fifty percent would be okay nine percent
extraordinary keep in mind that the
seasonal flu would get
anywhere between forty and seventy
percent effectiveness experts say we
still need a lot more information the
trial isn't complete yet
the side effect profile we don't have
long-term data
we don't have demographic data so we
certainly need to hear
much more about this but this is really
the first that we've heard
of some significant successes in a phase
three clinical trial
that's how we'll get through this winter
to a spring
and a summer that will be much better i
promise
the prime minister's stressing culvert
precautions are key now when a vaccine
can't help
and when it can canada has secured at
least 20 million doses of the pfizer
vaccine
beginning distribution in canada to high
priority groups that is
most likely to happen in q1 or in the
first three months
of 2021 but of course there is a lot of
uncertainty
the united kingdom and u.s are talking
about roll out before the end of this
year
canada isn't offering more specifics but
it is preparing
the pfizer vaccine needs to be kept very
cold we have minus
80 degree freezers we know how to make
more minus 80 degree freezers and we
have
the capacity to do this it also requires
two doses with the number of vaccines
that are still going through clinical
trials as well as those
that are in pre-clinical development we
still have a real
shock or feasible shot of getting to a
single shot vaccine
as for the pfizer vaccine it's now weeks
away from fda approval in the united
states
but getting the emergency use
authorization it's looking for
won't be a green light for us in canada
health canada will be making its own
decision on this
and any other vaccine donna
abigail beeman in ottawa thank you after
so many gloomy months today's promising
news injected some optimism into the
markets
some of the big winners were travel
companies and airlines air canada's
shares jumped more than 25
american airlines gained 15 percent and
cruise company carnival
saw its stock surge 39
a vaccine isn't going to change where
we're at right now and case numbers
along with hospitalizations are rising
across much of the country
more than 4 000 new cases were reported
in just 24 hours
over the weekend that is a record high
and today quebec reported more than 1
000 cases for a sixth straight day
five more people died there there were
more than 1200 positive tests in ontario
today and 12
more deaths none of it now has its
second
case it's connected to the same
household where the first case was
identified on friday
in the west alberta is reporting 644 new
cases and seven more people have died
in bc 462 new cases reported in the past
24 hours and five more deaths apart from
atlantic canada the spread of the virus
is ramping up fast
each province is taking a different
approach with restrictions
and the messaging can be confusing we
have coverage from across the country
tonight beginning
with mike gerlay in toronto life is
slowly getting back to normal just
outside of toronto in peel region
with so many people out and about you'd
never know it's the only region in
ontario
considered to be in the red zone
epidemiologists
are bewildered it's like saying we have
speed limits on the highway but that
speed limit is 300 miles per hour
so i think it's far too forgiving of
spread of
the disease and it's not the right
timing either we have a crisis right now
we should be looking at closing things
not allowing things to stay open
lockdowns don't appear to be in premier
doug ford's playbook anymore
he says he's looking for a happy balance
and that he's been bombarded by calls
from business owners
begging him to keep the province open
we're the lowest in north america
in any jurisdiction so as much as we're
seeing the numbers go up
we still have the the lowest numbers for
any large jurisdiction
but on the other side of the ledger is
the health argument any way you measure
it ontario is in crisis
two days in a row with over twelve
hundred new cases and a surging seven
day average
and when compared to the worst day the
province saw in april
ontario's numbers have doubled the stats
point to two main problem areas
community spread in close contact
testing hasn't increased
yet ontario's positive test rate is at
an alarming five percent
politically expert myers miataki says it
all adds up to ford
having a credibility problem i think
it's bewildering
why he's going in the direction that he
is and i think
until he can explain to ontarians
why that route makes sense i think it
only further undermines his position
until then ontario is open for business
i'm heather urich's west in alberta
where doctors are bracing for an
onslaught of covid19 patients
as the number of new infections
continues to surge
alberta's icu capacity for covet
patients is already hovering around 50
percent
but that number is expected to rise i'm
actually concerned that even the best
case scenario involves a real strain on
the health care system
and failure to get things under control
quickly could really magnify that
a month ago alberta was seeing about 250
new infections every day
but in just four weeks that number has
tripled and alberta's public health
system
is struggling to cope contact tracing is
very overwhelmed in alberta
and now a lot of the contact pricing is
being put on the shoulders of albertans
rather than the contact racers
to be blunt all that we have
accomplished together
is now at risk on friday alberta's
premier said the rising case numbers
need to be taken
seriously but the province stopped short
of implementing any mandatory
restrictions
it's voluntary this is a strong request
that albertans and edmonton and calgary
stop holding social gatherings at their
homes that they just
keep to their core family group at home
uh period i think if people
truly um stuck to what is recommended
then i think that we could see a decline
but i think what we're seeing is that
that's not being done
instead many on the front lines say it's
time for the province to take more
drastic action
a short sharp period of lockdown to give
the province's health system a chance
to get things back under control we're
essentially the canary in the coal mine
in this kind of situation and
and we are telling the premier that we
are concerned and i don't feel our
concerns are being listened to
i'm robin gill in british columbia where
a second wave of covet 19 has brought in
new restrictions
no gatherings at homes no fitness
classes
limited sports activities over the next
two weeks we need to reduce our social
contacts and we need to
make sure that we're staying local
restaurants in bc were told
they're safe spots because so far there
is no evidence of covet 19 transmission
nothing changes because in restaurants
it's six or fewer people in bubbles that
you trust
so they could be a work bubble it could
be a volunteer bubble they could be your
immediate household bubble
the new rules needed some clarification
though at first
only members of an immediate household
could get together
the messaging changed to include the
people you spend the most time with
this latest action in our covet 19
response is about
putting the brakes on the virus breaking
those chains of transmission
it is a short-term pause on
non-essential activities
the metro vancouver area has seen a
disturbing and record-breaking spike in
cases
take this modeling done for the bc
center for disease control
it's not a predictor but shows where
things are going
yellow is the current growth the other
colors show what can happen
if there's reduced contact if we do
something great for two weeks but then
we return to what we've been doing in
the past three weeks
the cases will just pick up again bc was
the envy of the country at the beginning
of this pandemic with its low cases
not anymore robin gill global news
vancouver
manitoba's chief public health officer
is considering tougher restrictions
because kovig 19 keeps spreading there
manitoba reported 365 new cases today
and three
more deaths and the test positivity rate
is 9.5 percent
the bulk of the new cases are in
winnipeg the province is investigating
outbreaks at two long-term care homes as
well where 36 residents have died
hospital icu's are nearing capacity
we're at a at a critical point where we
need to
change these dynamics it all comes down
to reducing our contacts
the atlantic bubble is holding for the
most part nova scotia reported one new
case today and it announced
a clampdown on travel anyone arriving in
nova scotia from outside the atlantic
travel bubble
must now self-isolate for 14 days away
from other family members
if that can't be done then anyone living
with that individual must isolate as
well
and nobody from that household can go to
work or school
now to the united states the numbers are
staggering there nearly 10
million people are known to have had
covid19 and more than
237 thousand americans have died
new data out today shows 43 u.s states
are reporting at least a 10 percent rise
in cases compared to last week
tonight hospitals in 22 states have
record high
hospitalizations and america's seven day
average has also hit a record with more
than one hundred thousand new cases
reported
every 24 hours in the past week
a new president and a new plan to combat
covet 19
coming up what joe biden wants everyone
in the u.s to do
and life in the fast lane the potential
future
of transportation
i want to congratulate president-elect
biden and vice president-elect
harris i'm looking forward to working
with them both on the common challenges
and opportunities facing our countries
and our world
prime minister justin trudeau was the
first world leader to speak with the
president-elect of the united states joe
biden in a phone call earlier today
kovit 19 was top of the agenda biden has
moved his transition plans into high
gear and the man who remains president
until january
is still refusing to concede jackson
prescott reports
72 days before his inauguration joe
biden laid out his plans for day one on
the job
i will be a president for every american
this election is over with the pandemic
now surging beyond control
in most states biden has already
established a panel of expert advisors
like dr rick bright the whistleblower
fired by the trump
administration the president-elect is
also making a national plea for all
americans to wear masks immediately
we can save tens of thousands of lives
if everyone would just wear a mask
for the next few months the normally
stayed process of presidential
transition has been upended by an
outgoing president who refuses to
concede
the practice in recent years has been a
pretty strong norm
that the the outgoing administration
does what it can to facilitate and
smooth the way
for the new administration to come in
instead donald trump has spent his days
falsely insisting the election was
stolen
while his campaign continues making
unproven claims of widespread voter
fraud
state officials who ran the election
even republican ones
say it's just not true we know the
system counted properly we know the
ballots that were there were counted
properly and correctly we know that
most of the court challenges launched by
the trump campaign have already been
dismissed for lack of evidence
still trump's republican backers in
washington are standing by him for now
cutting him a wide berth to make
baseless accusations about the vote
the president has every right to look
into allegations and to request
recounts under the law while all this
plays out president trump remains
largely hidden from public view
but in a tweet he announced the sudden
firing of the secretary of defense
raising fears he might undertake a
broader purge of government before his
own exit
in january donna
all right jackson proskow in washington
thanks still ahead ottawa's slow
progress on faster internet
for rural canadians
[Music]
those are the first passengers on the
virgin hyperloop that had a test run in
las vegas
hurdling them down a vacuum tube at high
speed it's hoped it could one day
revolutionize high-speed travel
the electronic transport system uses
magnetic levitation technology to propel
pods at speeds of up to one thousand
kilometers an hour
it still needs more testing before it
gets certified as safe
looping canada's rural communities into
high-speed internet services taking far
longer than expected
because so many people are working from
home now fast and reliable internet
service is more vital than ever
today ottawa promised to spend an
additional 750 million dollars to extend
broadband service to remote areas
but it is a promise that has been made
before as michael likature
reports good reliable internet
isn't a luxury it's a basic service
by that measure remote communities have
been deprived for years
according to canada's radio television
and telecommunications regulator
nearly 41 percent of homes in rural
areas have
access to high-speed broadband internet
as a whole
over 85 percent of canadians do the
newly announced 1.75 billion dollar
universal broadband fund
hopes to close that gap that's going to
provide
every community across this country
who's got shovel ready projects ready to
go with an opportunity to apply
and get connected within the next year
the goal is to get
98 of canadian homes connected to
high-speed internet by the year 2026.
high-speed internet is defined as 50
megabit per second download speed
and 10 megabit upload speed and the
pandemic has exposed canada's digital
divide
there are people that can't work from
home they can't actually do their
education from home
they don't have the option of having a
video conference with their doctor for a
prescription but have to go into the
office consecutive governments have made
similar broadband promises all the way
back to 2008.
monday's announcement was made 18 months
ago by the liberals and opposition
parties say
the government is dragging its feet what
we're hearing from a lot of smaller
internet service providers that they've
already lost this year
and they're not going to be able to get
shovels in the ground until some point
next year
after the winter that could delay the
plan to have high speed internet in
every home
by the year 2030 mike lecouter global
news ottawa
next the canadian who returned from the
first world war only to face the grief
of a pandemic
remembrance day is going to look
different this year people won't be able
to gather the way they usually do
but families across this country will
still honor those who fought and never
came home
more than a century ago it was not only
the first world war that led to millions
of deaths
but a flu pandemic and for some families
it was a double blow
redmond shannon has the story of one of
those families
so this is a picture of of james and
ellen
taken in 1916. genealogist
eunice robinson lives in the past unlike
her husband barry
my husband is the original non-gen and
the non-gen is the
term i coined to say somebody who could
absolutely care less about genealogy
but exploring barry's family history is
one of the most
interesting projects she's worked on in
1907 his great-grandfather james baird
brown left scotland with his wife and
children
to start a new life in winnipeg seven
years later
war broke out and their sons james jr
and george
enlisted with canada's 44th battalion
their father then 53 wanted to fight
too so he lied about his age saying he
was
43. you hear about the youngers often
saying they're older
but rarely do you hear about the older
saying that they're younger so
i guess he felt extremely patriotic i
believe when he finally got
to england they thought hey you're too
old fella
so they put him to work in the
quartermaster's office where i guess he
did quite a good job
in october 1916 george was killed in
battle
one of the more than 24 000 canadian
deaths
in the brutal and infamous psalm
offensive
george is buried at the adenac military
cemetery in northern france
before the war was over james senior by
then aged 55
was discharged for being over age and
returned to winnipeg
just weeks after the war ended james jr
married a british war bride tying the
knot at this
church in london around that time james
senior
returned to europe to find his younger
son's grave
while in london he most likely stayed on
this street at james junior's home
but he contracted influenza during the
spanish flu pandemic that was killing
millions
and he died aged 56. who can envision
what the world would have been like with
a previous pandemic
and this has really brought it home and
you kind of wonder
where you really are maybe put in a
position where
you have no control over getting this
disease
james jr returned to winnipeg two years
later
he died there in 1953 taking with him
the answer to a mystery about his dad's
final journey to europe i don't really
know if he ever found george's graveyard
that was done under the canadian war
graves commission so
a good chance that he may not have i
don't really know all those answers and
unfortunately i don't think there's
anyone living that still does
perhaps it's enough to know that james
senior paid the ultimate price trying to
find his son's final resting place
redmond shannon global news london
and that is global national for this
monday i'm donna friesen tonight here
canada is the sun
starting to set over vancouver thanks
for watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
you